nous retrouvons pierre henry président
de l'association france fraternité
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france les migrants sont
aujourd'hui confrontés un double
problème d'un côté parce que les
autorités locales de bosnie peuvent
refuser les décisions du gouvernement
fédéral de l'autre ils sont
régulièrement refoulés vers la bosnie
quand il essaie de passer en croatie
c'est votre constat aussi oui votre
reportage est très bien fait alors
rappelons que la bosnie c'est trois
millions cinq cent mille habitants
et c'est un système politique est
extrêmement compliqué entre la
fédération de bosnie herzégovine la
fédération de bosnie serbe est un autre
district et donc les décisions
politiques sont extrêmement difficiles à
prendre et de plus ce qui est en train
de se passer en bosnie était tout à fait
prévisible
auparavant les migrants se trouvaient
dans un camp à biak et rien n'a été fait
en prévision de l'hiver
autrement dit cette crise elle était
totalement prévisible alors les
organisations internationales mais aussi
l'union européenne ont appelé la bosnie
à trouver une solution humanitaire le
plus rapidement possible le problème
c'est que ce genre de situation va
évidemment se reproduire aux frontières
de l'union
et notamment avec la mise en place du
nouveau pacte pour les migrations et les
îles c'est à dire que l'union européenne
se protège et protège et évidemment ses
frontières on ne saurait lui en vouloir
cela étant vous avez des populations qui
fuient des situations de guerre civile
larvée d'ailleurs environ 8500 réfugiés
en bosnie et la bosnie on le rappelle
qui est l'un des pays les plus pauvres
d'europe l'union européenne a fourni au
pays quelques 85 5 millions d'euros
depuis 2018 pour faire face à la
migration et pourtant c'est un échec
visiblement c'est un échec parce que les
autorités bosniaques ne prennent pas les
mesures nécessaires pour accueillir dans
la dignité les les personnes vous savez
ces gens ils viennent principalement
d'afghanistan et du bangladesh et ça
fait des mois et des mois qui sont
bloqués sur la bosnie alors certains
réussiront à passer en croatie au prix
au prix fort si j'ose dire et essayer de
rentrer dans l'union européenne c'est un
vrai parcours de galériens donc on ne
peut aujourd'hui que déplorer cette
situation est appelée la bosnie à faire
preuve de retenue et surtout ce qu'elle
met en place les solutions humanitaire
minimale je rappelle que la bosnie les
candidates à entrer dans l'union
européenne et qu'il y à un certain
nombre de conditions et notamment le
respect des droits de l'homme
manifestement on en est loin
dans ce pays même si je note que les
appels de l'union européenne peuvent
être parfois regardé avec comme étant
des appels quelque peu hypocrite mais
internationale pour les migrations qui
gère le camp avec d'autres ong a décidé
de retirer ses équipes et réclament aux
autorités de bosnie trouve rire nous
sentons que le centre d'accueil pardon
de bira dans une ville voisine est ce
que selon vous ce serait la solution
oui mais on revient à les situer sio
qui existait auparavant parce que les
migrants au mois de juin dernier était
dans ce camp
et puis ils ont été déplacées et
d'ailleurs ce camp très précaire mais il
a au moins l'électricité l'eau et les
gens ne se retrouverait pas sous un
village de tentes ou du moins ce qu'il
en reste sans chauffage sans nourriture
ces gens sans entrain littéralement de
d'être soumis au froid et à la fin et ce
sont des traitements absolument
inappropriée inacceptable voilà donc
l'union européenne a donné de l'argent à
la base il faut maintenant que la bosnie
prenne sa part de responsabilité merci
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne pierre
et président de l'association france
fraternité